- Thank you, thank you for
coming to this session.
It's so early on a Monday
and it's almost like
all of us here are kicking
off this re:Invent 2025.
So, you know, kudos to all of us.
My name is Raghu,
I'm a technical product manager at,
a product marketing manager at AWS.
I've been with the company
almost 10 years in a few weeks.
So, welcome to today's session,
which is Enabling AI Innovation
with Amazon SageMaker
Unified Studio, okay?
I'll kick things off,
and I have two other speakers here today.
Terri Sutherland.
She is the general
manager for data platforms
at Commonwealth Bank of Australia.
So for short, you know,
we'll call it CommBank.
So she's gonna come on,
and then we have our star
solution architect, Praveen,
who is also from Australia.
So very thankful to Terri
and Praveen for coming here
all the way from Australia
to do this session with us.
So, oh, I should have done this first.
So this is today's agenda.
So like I said, I'm gonna kick
things off, set the stage,
and then I'm going to
hand this off to Terri.
Terri is going to walk us
through CommBank's journey
using SageMaker Unified Studio
and some of the other
capabilities within SageMaker.
Problem statement, outcomes,
impact that they have had in the bank.
And then Praveen is going to come on
and he is going to walk us
through the architecture
that they built within
CommBank and also do a demo.
So this is going to get very technical
once Praveen comes on,
and I'm sure, you know,
those bits are going to be
some of the more exciting parts
of today's presentation.
So.
Okay.
so we're gonna start off with
some data, some research.
So this is a research analysis done
by Harvard Business Review this year.
And basically what they are telling us
is 89% of CDOs have an initiative
to build applications
using AI and generative AI.
So majority of them are
building applications with AI
and gen AI, but an
overwhelming 52% of those CDOs
don't think they are ready
to embark on the AI journey.
And the reason for that is
they don't have enough trust
in their own data.
They don't have enough
faith in their own data
because they don't know their data.
So as much as we all want
to do exciting things
with AI and generative AI,
agentic this and agentic that,
I hate to break it to you.
We kind of have to go back to the basics
and get our house in order with our data.
So what does that mean?
It means building a sound data foundation
within the organization, okay?
And at AWS, we look at this as
two very broad things, okay?
Well, how do you build a data foundation?
We're gonna talk about that a little bit.
And then we look at this
as two very broad things.
One is improving data literacy
within the organization,
which is, do you know about your data?
Do you know what's good?
Do you know what good looks like?
These are not easy
questions to answer, okay?
So improve the data literacy
within the organization,
and the second is build
a data culture, okay?
And we will look at these
two parts, you know,
a brief overview of what this means,
and then, you know, we'll go
to CBA story or CommBank story.
Okay.
So I may have spent majority of my time
here at AWS doing this with our customers.
And I believe that most folks who are here
can relate to many projects that
you may be currently working
on that does this exact thing.
So there are seven data actions
as part of improving data
literacy within the organization.
This is not an exhaustive list, you know,
this is some of the main
items that most customers do
to improve the data literacy
within their organization.
Let's just kind of go
through this one by one,
you know, 20, 30 seconds each.
Build a data inventory.
What does that mean?
It can mean different things,
but broadly this is what it is.
It is a directory, a
list of all your data,
and that includes tables,
that includes S3 buckets,
you know, with structured
data, S3 buckets with images.
It also includes
applications like dashboards,
models, all of it, okay?
You should build a list of all that data.
We call them data assets, okay?
This in itself can be a
pretty elaborate topic,
but I'm gonna just do this really quickly.
You can build this a few different ways.
One is you can start at
the bottom with the data
and build an inventory
off that, which is tables,
S3 buckets, and so on.
Some customers like to do it from the top,
which is from the application side.
They like to build an inventory
off their BI dashboards
and models and then work their way down.
Some customers just start
with a line of business,
figure it out, and get a process going
in terms of building that inventory
and then rinse and repeat that
from line of business to line of business.
And CommBank is going to talk
a little bit more about that.
So that's what building
a data inventory means
at a high level.
Second is data annotation.
And this is probably the most boring part
of the whole journey, but
there is generative AI
to help all of us, but
what does that mean?
When you build a data
inventory, what does it contain?
It just contains metadata, you know?
Just cryptic table names and column names,
and no one can really make sense out of it
whether humans or agents
can make sense out of technical data.
And in most cases, we
will all get it wrong.
So data annotation means putting,
describing, describing technical data
and giving it business context.
This is customer table for product X,
this is a regional
customer table, et cetera.
Someone or something will have
to go and annotate this data.
And like I said, not very
exciting, but very important.
From there, detection of PII data.
If you're going to be
doing modeling, training,
you're retraining a foundational model.
You do not want PII data
as part of that project.
So detection of PII data, super important.
Once you detect PII data,
what do you do next?
You categorize it.
Most sensitive, least
sensitive, et cetera,
that fits your company's security SLAs.
From there, data quality.
How good is this data?
We all talk about bad data.
How bad is it?
So data quality is part of
building the data literacy
within the organization.
Then lineage, most people
here probably know what it is.
Data origin, data transformation.
Where did this data come from?
You know, that's being tracked.
And then finally,
publishing new data assets.
So this is one of the areas
where I have seen customers struggle with.
You do all of it, but your
data inventory is not static.
Your data inventory is ever changing.
So you have to build the practice
where when you do all of this,
this is a significant investment.
New assets are created every day.
You gotta put it back in the inventory.
So it's a practice, it's a habit.
Many customers do it really well.
A lot of customers are still
trying to figure it out.
Okay.
Like I said, been doing
this for a long time.
And I just want to just
leave you with this,
you know, and a couple more slides.
Choose your own journey with this
in improving the data literacy
within the organization.
What I have on the screen,
it's just a recommendation,
it's a suggestion, but
choose your own adventure
in improving the data literacy
within your companies.
Most companies start with PII
because they want to de-risk, okay?
Then they go to data
quality and then inventory.
So, so on, right?
So pick your journey and then stick to it.
So this is, if you take a
step back and look at it,
and even if you did, four
or five of these things,
you will be significantly improving
the data literacy footprint
within the organization.
Okay.
So that's data literacy.
Second, building a data culture.
The best way to explain this,
we all have learned to be
very social digitally, right?
You know, with Facebooks and
in LinkedIns of the world.
We all have built a pretty
good social culture.
The same thing applies to data culture.
I'm just gonna draw some parallels here.
When you want to make a social platform,
okay, either it is for videos
or whether it's for data,
you really have three things.
You have producers, content creators,
you have consumers who consume
what the producers create,
and they like, comment, use.
And then there is a third party,
which is the central team.
The central team provides
you with the platform.
They provide you with guardrails,
policies, best practices,
do's and don'ts, so the whole activity
of being social is sustainable.
CommBank built this and
they will walk you through
their story, how they started,
and how they built once
they kind of got it right,
and how they kind of
expanded their expertise
and built the data culture
within the organization.
So this is extremely important.
And again, when you build a data culture,
it really needs to be in
the organization's DNA.
It needs to sustain executive churns.
So like I said, these things take time.
You have to build it over time
and you gotta make that a habit
within the entire company.
Okay, so we talked about data foundations,
we talked about data literacy,
we talked about how you
build a data culture,
and none of these things
had anything to do
with AWS services.
These are just in a good data practices.
So how can we help you?
If this is important to you,
if PII detection,
building a data inventory,
building the data culture
is important to you,
well, how do you get started?
Well, last re:Invent, re:Invent 2024,
we released, we rereleased,
relaunched, I should say,
Amazon SageMaker, okay?
It is our data and AI platform.
It's got lots of features and functions
and we broadly look at Amazon SageMaker
like a three-layer cake, okay?
We'll go from bottom up.
At the bottom, we have the
lakehouse architecture,
all Iceberg-based data architectures,
Iceberg REST Catalog functionality,
lot of managed capabilities
built into our lakehouse.
So we got sessions on lakehouse,
so definitely check those out.
And on top of it is the
data in AI governance.
Most of what I just talked
about in the last 10, 12 minutes
fits into this data and
AI governance capabilities
built in Amazon SageMaker, okay?
And at the top, we have
unified data experience.
Well, what does that mean?
So you got a lakehouse,
you have good data
governance capabilities,
which means you can search data,
you can find data, get access to data.
Then what do you do with it?
Well, that's where the
UnifiedUI comes into picture.
SQL capabilities, data processing,
building data pipelines,
generative AI app development are all part
of our Unified user experience.
But obviously we are not stopping there.
We are, you know,
building more capabilities
like streaming and BI
and even search analytics
and some of these capabilities
will come in 2026.
So this is just zooming into
the Unified Studio
experience within SageMaker.
As you can imagine, this
is meant for data workers,
whether you are doing SQL,
whether you're doing modeling,
training, building pipelines,
we have notebooks as you can imagine.
We have notebook experiences
built into the studio.
We have query editors
We have, this is my favorite,
visual low-code, no-code experience
built into the studio as well,
which means you can build data pipelines,
you can build, you know, ETL
jobs with absolutely no code.
And then we also have
generative AI chatbot
building experiences as well.
And then it's my last slide
before I, you know,
get Terri on the stage.
So this is the second
layer of Amazon SageMaker,
and this is, like I said,
most of what I discussed,
which is data literacy and
building the data culture
within the organization
are all part of the data
and AI governance
functionality within SageMaker.
You can do PII detection, you
can do data quality checks.
We have an awesome business data catalog,
awesomely priced, almost free.
So it's got great capabilities, you know,
definitely check those out.
And then, you know,
hopefully you start building
your amazing data practice
on Amazon SageMaker.
Before I get Terri on, I
do wanna mention one thing.
You saw the three layers.
I should have said this
a couple of slides ago.
You saw the three layers.
You don't have to use all
of it all at the same time.
You can start your journey anywhere, okay?
If data governance is the
most burning problem for you,
then you can start with data governance.
If lakehouse, then start with lakehouse.
And then you don't have to use everything.
We truly believe if you use all of it,
you will get the best experience,
but you don't have to.
You can start somewhere and
then expand your overall usage
of Amazon SageMaker as the needs come.
Terri.
Thanks, folks.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, thank you.
Thanks very much.
Hi everyone.
Thank you, Raghu.
Really pleased to be here.
My name's Terri Sutherland.
I'm the general manager of
the cloud data platforms
at the Commonwealth Bank of Australia
and I'm super excited to be here today
to talk to you about our
ambitious strategy and AI roadmap
and transformation journey.
But first let me tell you a little bit
about the bank itself.
Though many of you have
probably never heard
of the Commonwealth Bank of
Australia or CBA as we call it,
we are Australia's largest bank.
Australia's population
is 27 million people.
And CBA services 17.5 million customers.
That means one in three Australians
and one in three businesses bank with us.
Overall, 50% of
transactions go through CBA,
and on the global stage we
are the 13th largest bank
by value, by market value.
And I'm excited to say
that we've just been named
top four bank globally for AI maturity.
Oops, sorry.
Didn't realize you hadn't moved the slide.
Given the importance of CBA
to the Australian economy,
our data and AI strategy
is one of the bank's most valuable assets.
It underpins everything we do.
From protecting our customers
against frauds and scam
to delivering seamless
personalized experiences.
Whether you're accessing cash at an ATM,
paying for groceries, or
applying for a home loan.
Data and AI powers the services
that our customers rely on every day.
At the heart of this strategy
are three core pillars.
Firstly, and always most
importantly, our people.
Like many organizations, we
realized central engineering
and AI teams just couldn't scale.
So our first step of our
strategy was to decentralize
and embed our data engineers
and data scientists
across the lines of business in the bank.
By doing this, we brought the data and AI
closer to the people who use it
and closer to the people
we serve, our customers.
Our second pillar is safeguards.
We're a bank, we manage
sensitive customer information.
So we've designed governance and controls
to be inherent in every single stage
of the data and AI life cycle,
ensuring safety by design.
And finally, our third pillar, technology.
This is where our partnership
with AWS comes in.
We needed to take decades of rich data
spread across hundreds of source systems
and put it into the hands
of our federated data and AI teams.
To achieve this, we established
a data mesh ecosystem
that empowers our federated
teams to operate independently.
It moves data seamlessly,
ensures access for people and machine,
all the while enforcing strict governance.
We call this ecosystem CommBank.data.
Today it provides our 40 lines
of business across the bank,
the freedom to produce and use data
all within a trusted,
traceable, controlled framework.
By decentralizing, we adopted
a clear producer-consumer model.
Each business unit now owns managers
and manages this data as a product
with defined roles and responsibilities.
We also introduce
self-service data sharing
through a unified data marketplace,
a single pane of glass where
users can discover, request,
and consume data across
the entire AWS ecosystem.
But here's the reality, data has gravity.
Where the data lives is where
every single data engineer
and data scientist in the bank will work.
Historically, CBA had decades
of rich data held in on-premise platforms.
Platforms that lacked interoperability
or could not scale for AI.
And so we made a bold move.
We migrated 61,000
on-premise data pipelines
to our AWS mesh ecosystem
that's equivalent
of 10 petabytes of data.
The migration took us nine months
with 100% of data pipelines
tested at least three times.
That's 229,000 tests.
And in so doing, we moved
our entire data engineering
and AI workforce to AWS cloud.
To make all of this real, we had to run
two major programs in parallel,
migration and marketplace.
We migrated over 10 petabytes of data
from on-premise to AWS cloud
and built the data marketplace
aligned to our federated,
decentralized operating model.
We started with migration.
Earlier last year, we kicked
off a series of workshops
with AWS to test our
most complex data flows
and AI use cases to see if the migration
to AWS native technologies was possible.
We call this approach steel threads.
Like an MVP or a proof of concept,
steel threads proves the technology fit,
but also productionalizes the outcome.
We built AI and generative
AI that transformed code,
check for errors, and tested output,
reconciling every single table
to our on-premise platform 100%.
Every single row, column, and number
had to be accounted for.
But this was more than a
tech builder migration.
It was also a major
change management effort.
We onboarded federated data teams
through 200 tailored sessions
and trained over 1,000 engineers,
embedding change, building capability,
and driving sustained adoption.
And throughout, we also worked closely
with local and international regulators
to ensure compliance and continuity.
Now let's talk about the
second major stream of work,
building the data marketplace.
This was a fundamental shift
in how we think about data ownership
and access across the bank.
Each line of business
was becoming a producer,
a consumer, and many cases, both.
We started by building
our technical foundations,
a federated data mesh
platform designed for scale,
governance, and decentralized ownership.
As we transitioned from a monolithic
to a composable platform,
we faced the challenge
how to seamlessly connect hundreds of
line of business owned AWS accounts
while keeping the user
experience frictionless.
So we implemented a abstraction layer,
one that could unify access to data,
offer flexibility in
compute and UI choices,
and uphold our rigorous
governance standards.
Praveen will bring that experience to life
in a demo shortly.
Once that was all in place,
we implemented AWS DataZone
to enable discovery,
access, and sharing
across the organization,
bringing on early adopters.
And with the launch of
SageMaker Unified Studio,
earlier this year, we added in
a single pane of glass
experience so everyone
from analysts to executives
could see and use
the data they needed.
In completing this, we
aligned our engineers,
onboarded producers and
consumers, to a shared framework,
one that creates self-service
while maintaining governance
and interoperability across the mesh.
And now with the right
data in the right place,
we're ready to scale with governed AI.
Let's look at the benefits
of what this transformation
is allowing us to do today.
When we spoke to our
engineers and data scientists,
they told us CommBank.data marketplace
has transformed the way they work.
Now they connect directly
from their local VS code environment,
no longer restricted to
SageMaker or remote platforms.
This access streamlines workflows
and speeds up experimentation.
On the standout features
is a single pane of glass experience.
Instead of switching between
tools and interfaces,
teams have a unified dashboard
for data discovery,
analytics, and monitoring.
The Spark UI is easily accessible,
allowing real-time tracking
of query performance
and quick identification of bottlenecks.
Dedicated compute resources also means
workflows run reliably and troubleshooting
is far more simple if problems arise.
The integration with
SageMaker was a game changer.
Data labs outputs are now available
directly within the platform,
removing manual steps and making it easier
to run advanced analytics and
machine learning workloads.
These improvements have
created a unified environment
that empowers our teams to experiment,
deploy, and scale AI with ease.
It helps us build a
culture of AI innovation
where our people are closer to the data
and scaling AI with confidence.
So we've achieved a lot
in the past 18 months.
We built a strategic mesh
ecosystem in AWS cloud.
We migrated decades of investment
to that cloud ecosystem
and onboarded data and engineers,
data engineers and data scientists to AWS
and innovative tooling.
But what did we learn along the way?
We could not scale with data and AI
with centralized operating
model and monolithic platforms.
We needed to train our people
to understand the new
federated operating model
and allow time for engineers
and data scientists to become
certified in the new tooling.
MVPs, steel threads, and iteration
are our path to discovery
and in fact the fastest way
to true value outcomes for our customers.
And importantly, we needed to recognize
that transformation is
always a learning curve,
which means being
comfortable with the unknown.
Looking ahead, we'll continue
onboarding our lines of business
and maturing with them,
expanding generative AI,
Unified Studio including
Amazon Q and agentic AI
and deepening lineage
explainability and observability.
Next, Praveen will show you
this unified experience works
and end-to-end SageMaker Unified Studio
for the CommBank.data marketplace
so you can see the
architecture come to life.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Terri.
It's been a pleasure to collaborate
and work alongside CommBank data team
on this very exciting data
transformation program.
I strongly believe that the
team has built a highly scalable
and a future fit modern data platform
that is going to help
accelerate time to insights,
is going to increase
organizational agility,
and at the same time meet
all of the strict governance
and regulatory obligations.
My name is Praveen Kumar.
I'm a principal AI
solutions architect at AWS.
And the next 20 minutes or so,
I'm going to take you through
CommBank data platform,
how we'll design, platform architecture,
and I'll also have a
short demo to show you
an end-to-end user experience
in a multi-account environment.
And that's how CommBank
data platform is set up.
But before that, I would
like to acknowledge
CommBank data team and
particularly Olatunde Baruwa
who's a chief engineer at CommBank.
They have been instrumental
in the implementation
and the execution of this data platform.
As Terri shared, the data
transformation program
included two major streams of work.
The first one was about migrating
our on-premise Hadoop-based
data lake platform
with over 10 petabytes of data to AWS.
And the second program involved
setting up an internal data marketplace
that aligned with targeted
state federated operating model
where each line of business,
there are 40 of them,
will act as data producer
or data consumer or both.
And the central team will
provide lightweight governance
while facilitating the
marketplace ecosystem.
So let's look at the
migration program first.
What you see here is the high level design
and the key components of
the on-premise platform
before and after migration.
On the left is the setup
before the migration.
The on-premise platform was made up
of two large scale Hadoop clusters.
One of the cluster was used
to run 61,000 pipelines
and then data and metadata was copied
to the other Hadoop cluster
to serve interactive workload.
When this platform was moved to cloud,
it was mainly done through
a lift and shift approach.
So data was migrated to Amazon S3
and compute is now powered by Amazon EMR.
However, one of the key
benefit when migrating
Hadoop-based data lake platform to cloud
is that there is separation
of a storage and compute.
Because all of the data is in Amazon S3,
the team is able to
enable access of this data
to variety of cloud native
analytics and ML engines
to support diverse set of use cases.
Next is federation.
Previously, the team built,
managed, and supported
on-premise data lake
platform that was monolithic.
However, in the federated
setup, each line of business,
there are 40 of them, have their
own dedicated AWS accounts.
They use Amazon S3 to store their data
in Apache Iceberg format.
They built pipelines using
either EMR Serverless or Redshift
or other third party engines.
They use Glue to store technical metadata,
lake formation for
policy stored, and so on.
But more importantly,
LOBs are now responsible
for building and managing
their own data assets,
their own data pipelines,
their orchestration.
They're responsible for the
data quality of these assets,
SLAs, observability, and more.
So as the platform evolved
from a monolithic unit
to a distributed and composable construct,
we needed to build an abstraction layer
that would bring all
of these LOBs together.
So there are two key requirements.
The first one was to build
an enterprise-wide business data catalog
where data producers
can publish data assets
and data products, and
data consumers can search,
discover these assets, and
request access to these assets.
The second key requirement was to provide
an integrated builder
experience for all data users.
Users such as data engineers,
data analysts, data scientists
to use user interface of their choice.
This could be notebooks,
query editors, visual ETL.
And then we also be able to leverage
a variety of compute engines
that's optimized for their use case.
And so to support these
two key requirements,
the team onboarded Amazon
SageMaker Unified Studio.
SageMaker Unified Studio
provides an integrated
developer experience for all data users
to build data and AI-driven applications.
It has got governance built
in with SageMaker catalog.
The teams were also able to leverage
many of the construct within
SageMaker Unified Studio
for broader governance.
For example, they use domain units
to replicate organizational hierarchy
and implement governance policies.
They used projects to isolate workloads
and map to hundreds of AWS accounts,
and they use the pops up model
within SageMaker Unified Studio
to integrate with third party engines.
Now, earlier this year, we migrated
the on-premise Hadoop based
data lake platform to AWS.
This has almost all of CBA data.
We are talking about tens
of thousands of tables.
However, this is monolithic in nature.
In parallel, we started onboarding
various lines of business
to the internal data marketplace,
and this platform is federated
and distributed in nature.
So the next challenge was how
do we bring them together.
So we did that in two steps.
The first was to identify
the line of business owner
for each table that has
been migrated to AWS now
within the data marketplace.
And so the idea was to provide
the necessary governance.
For example, a business
owner is now responsible
for approving the usage and access
of that table or data asset.
The second step was to enable
the technical integration.
And this is going back
to my earlier point.
Because all of the migrated
data is in Amazon S3,
we built a lightweight ETL
job that replicates metadata
from RDS Hive Metastore
to Glue Data Catalog.
So you have all of the tables now
appearing in Glue Data Catalog.
And then we mapped each of those tables
to the respective SageMaker
project under their LOB.
Now since all of the data is available
in the centralized SageMaker data catalog,
data consumers can come
to a central place,
which is the studio.
They can browse, discover, request access.
And once the access is approved,
they can build their applications
through a query in place architecture
across hundreds of AWS accounts.
So there is no data movement.
Data can be living in many
of these AWS accounts,
but we're able to use compute
from any of these accounts
with the right governance.
All right, so now it's time
to see all of this in action.
The demo is partly inspired by
how common data platform is set up.
So you'll be using a
multi-account environment.
The demo use case is building
a fraud detection model
for a financial services organization.
We'll have two user personas in this demo.
We have got Samantha or Sam.
She's a data engineer.
She's part of retail banking team,
so that's a LOB line of business.
She's going to create a new table
called customer_profile table
by combining data from two existing table
that her team owns.
She's then able to,
she's then going to enrich the metadata.
So she's going to add a README,
she's going to add data quality, lineage.
And once the metadata is enriched,
she's going to publish it to the catalog
for others to discover and request access.
She's also responsible
for approving access
to the subscription
requests on LOB's behalf.
The second user persona is Javier.
He's a data scientist and
part of financial crime team.
He's going to build the
fraud detection model.
And to do that, he needs
access to the various datasets.
So he'll go to the catalog
where he can centrally
discover all of the assets
and request access to this new
table that Sam has created.
Once the access is approved,
Javier is going to do
some interactive analysis
and then build a ML model
using SageMaker AI API.
Here is the setup.
So this is the multi-account
environment setup.
At the top in this demo, I
have used three AWS accounts.
At the top is the shared services account.
So this account is owned
by the central team
and this is where
SageMaker domain is set up.
And then SageMaker domain is
hooked to two AWS accounts.
One is the data producer
account on the left
and the other is data
consumer account on the right.
So anything that Sam is using
in terms of storage and compute,
that's going to sit in
the producer account.
When she's building a pipeline using Spark
or when storing data in
S3, that's all going to be
in that leftmost account,
which is the producer account.
Anything that Javier is going to do,
so essentially, you know,
you're running Athena query
to do exploratory analysis
or using SageMaker AI
API to train the model,
that sits in the consumer
account on the right.
This pattern is scalable to
hundreds of AWS accounts,
and this provides you the best practices
in terms of setting up
multi-account strategy.
You get workload isolation,
you can allocate costs to respective LOBs,
and at the same time, you can implement
the distinct governance boundary.
All right.
I'll hit play.
So I'm in SageMaker Unified
Studio and I'm logged in as Sam.
So this is the homepage of
SageMaker Unified Studio.
And you can see at the top section
you have things like discover catalog,
you can play with the foundation model
through generative AI playground.
So let's, you know, as
one of the first action,
let's browse catalog.
So this is the catalog
view where you can discover
all of the organizational asset.
So at the top section,
you can type in a keyword,
it does semantic search,
and then it will return
the results, right?
So for example, I have a search for
a table called transaction, it showed up.
At the bottom half of the page,
what you see here is the
domain unit hierarchy.
So this maps to your LOB hierarchy.
In this case there are only two LOBs,
RetailBanking and FinCrime.
And then at the top is the project.
So project is a concept
where you map a project
to a use case which allows you to group
compute and data that
a team has access to.
So in this case I've got two projects,
RetailBanking data team
project that is aligned
to the retail banking team.
And this is where Sam is going to work.
And I've also got another project FinCrime
which Javier has access to,
and this is where, you
know, he's going to use
that project to train ML model.
So Sam is going to click on that project.
This is the project overview homepage.
We'll go through the menu
options on the left one by one,
but at the top on this page,
you can see the various project files.
This could be your notebook
files, query files and so on.
But important point to note
is this project role ARN
on the right side, so,
which I have highlighted.
And I can see that there
is an account number here.
This is the data producer account, right?
And this project role helps map
what compute and data access
that the team has as a
part of this project.
So in case of, you know, JVR,
this will be a different
role and a different account.
All right, so that's the
project overview homepage.
Next we will go and click on
the data on the left hand side.
And so this is all of the dataset
that the team has access to.
So, you know, any Glue
tables will show up.
In this case there are three Glue tables
that the team has already created.
If you have access to Redshift data,
that will show up here as
well as any S3 buckets.
Then there is the Compute tab,
which is where all of
the compute will show up.
So in this case the team has
access to Redshift Compute
as well as Glue Spark.
And you have access to
other compute like Hyperport
or MLflow Tracking Server,
all of that will appear here.
And this Members is, you
know, all of your team members
who are part of this project.
So essentially part of
retail banking team,
that will show up here.
On the bottom half of the left hand side
is the project catalog.
So this is where you build your catalog.
So you bring your table
from Glue Data Catalog
to SageMaker catalog inventory space
and this is where you enrich the metadata.
So you can add glossary,
metadata forms, data quality,
and I'll show you this in a while.
But for example, this team
has already got access
to three tables that they have enriched.
And this is showing up as customer,
customer account, and transactions.
All right, so the next step from here is,
let's say Sam wants to
build a new table, right?
They already have access to two tables,
customer and customer activity.
Now she's wanting to build a new table
called customer_profile.
So she comes to the Jupyter Notebook.
She sets some Glue Spark
config, like number of workers.
Run some selected statement, you know,
customer account and customers.
And at the bottom, there's a
cell called create table as
where essentially she combines data
from customer and customer account table
and creates a new customer_profile table.
So once that cell runs, you'll
see on the left-hand side
that we'll have fourth table appear
called customer_profile.
So that seller has executed
and now I can see the fourth table.
So I've created a new table
by combining information
from other tables that my team owns.
So the next step is I want to enrich
the metadata of this table.
So I come to the data source.
So I'm already creating an data source
that points to Glue Data Catalog
and I'll bring the metadata
to the inventory space.
So I have now run that data source,
I can see the new table is appearing here.
Now this is where you can
add things like README,
you can look at, you
know, the schema details.
So all of the columns will appear here.
Data quality is blank, we'll
populate it in a while.
And then it also shows you the lineage.
And this lineage is, you know,
as we're building the pipeline,
Glue Spark is already integrated
with SageMaker catalog.
So it's pulling all of
the lineage information
when we are ingesting the
metadata of that table.
So it shows you column level lineage
and this is open lineage compatible.
So from here, let's say
I want to add a README,
which is essentially looking
at the schema details
of this table and looking at
few records of this table,
I want to generate a summary.
Now you could do this
in a couple of phase,
you could have your steward
manually doing this task
or you can take advantage of agentic AI.
So when you go to the Jupyter Lab,
we have this agentic AI capability,
which is Q CLI integrated.
So I'm giving it a prompt,
I'm saying that I have a
table named customer_profile
in my Glue Data Catalog.
Can you generate a concise summary
of this dataset using schema details
and also looking at 10
records within the table?
And I then provide a helper
function which has details like
using the permission
scoped to the project,
which is the project role, as
well as the Athena work group
assigned to that project.
So I give that instruction.
Now this is where the agent is
planning out the set of steps
and then it's going to execute.
It fires up, you know,
Glue APIs to understand
if there's a table
which is similar looking
and it's able to detect that table.
And then it's going to
use Athena as an engine
to run a select star statement.
So this takes about a few seconds,
but once it completes, it
will save the description,
concise description into a
local file within the space.
If you want to look at the details,
what query it has generated,
you can, you know, just
expand one of the dropdown
and you can look at the query
that that agent has generated.
So just in few seconds, you'll see that
it has now created a directory.
Now it's creating a file
and it's going to save.
All right, so it has
already created the file
and saved the concise
description based on the schema
and the tender codes.
Next I want the agent
to use this information
that I just generated and I
want it to update the data asset
within the SageMaker catalog
with this information.
So update the README.
So I'm just saying that read
the dataset description file
generated above as part of
analysis of the specified table.
Format the content and
update the README section
of the data asset.
And I provide helper
function with an example API.
So then it's able to, you know,
compile the necessities and structure,
it self-correct itself in
case it's not able to post.
And again, within few seconds,
it's able to create an asset revision
within SageMaker catalog for this asset.
So it has completed that activity now.
If I go here and refresh,
I will see the README
section is populated.
Now this README section is fairly accurate
in terms of what that dataset is about.
Next, so we have got, we have enriched
the dataset with lineage, README.
Next if you want to, let's
say, run data quality checks,
that's another prompt you can run.
I'm saying that I have a dataset
and I want to run a data
quality for this table.
I would like you to create
two data quality rules,
check null values for each
column and email validation
and use Glue Spark engine to do that.
So again, it goes and plans,
it uses the Glue interactive session
in the context of the project.
It changes the Spark SQL.
And right now the data quality is null.
But once this finishes running
the data quality checks,
you'll see that data
quality will get populated.
And this is where it's save, like,
it has finished running
the data quality checks
and it's saving the results into
a file in the local directory.
And so one last prompt time entering is,
now take this information
that I just generated
in terms of data quality results
and populate the data quality section
within the SageMaker catalog.
And this is all running
in context of the project.
So the scope boundary is that project role
that I showed you.
So this has completed updating
the data quality rules.
And you can see here again
within minute or two,
you have got all of the
data quality results
appearing in the SageMaker catalog.
So now Sam is happy with
all of the enrichment.
So she has updated README,
lineage, and data quality.
So she's going to publish this asset,
which makes it discoverable
to anyone in the organization
who has access to the
SageMaker Unified Studio.
And this is that single
pane that we talked about.
So this customer_profile
table is appearing now.
I'm logged in as Javier
in a different browser.
So you can see it's a different user.
And this is the project overview homepage
and the project selected here is FinCrime.
So it's a different project.
You'll see here the project
role is a different role
and the account number is
that data consumer account
that I talked about earlier.
Javier and his team has access
to a different set of table.
So in this case, he has got access
to a table called transactions.
And he needs more dataset to
be able to build his ML model.
So he goes and types for any information
related to customer_profile.
He can see that there is a
table that has been created
and that exists in the catalog.
So he can analyze all of the
metadata, like column details,
data quality, lineage.
And if he's happy with
all of the information,
so he can also looks at who created this,
which team owns it.
But if he's happy with
all of the information,
he requests access to this table.
So it creates a subscription request.
And this request goes to Sam
who is the owner of the table.
So Sam can see there is
a subscription request
and she goes and reviews
the subscription request
where she can see details
like who has created it,
which team is it coming from,
and if she's happy with, you
know, all of the details,
she goes ahead and approves.
At this point, SageMaker
takes care of the fulfillment.
So even though the data is
located in a different account
and compute is in a different account,
it goes and execute the lake
formation API to, you know,
do the necessary policy
so that, now Javier,
once he goes and refreshes
his technical data catalog,
he will see that the
new table will appear.
So now he has access to
customer_profile table,
he'll run a quick select star.
So this query which he's using Athena
is running in the data consumer account.
So he's happy with all of the results.
And so one final step is
to build the ML model.
So I pre-created a notebook.
So Javier goes to the Jupyter lab.
I pre-created a notebook
and I've also taken
the help of agentic AI to kind
of generate this notebook.
But he goes and, you
know, runs Athena Query
for feature engineering.
He pre-process the data,
he prepares the data,
he uploads the data to S3,
and then eventually he trains the model
using SageMaker AI API.
This takes about few minutes to run,
so we won't probably
wait till this finishes,
but this is kind of the last
step in the process, right?
So that's the end of the demo.
Let's head back to the presentation now.
All right.
Now before I wrap up,
I'd like to emphasize on
a few key points that we
covered in our session today.
First, building data and
AI culture takes time.
So it's crucial that
you have executed buy-in
and that you stay invested.
Second, as you embark on your
data transformation journey,
it's important to start
with steel thread use cases
because not only it provides
immediate business value,
but it also helps with faster
iteration and feedback loop.
Third, your data is your
unique differentiator.
And so it's very important
that you have a strong
data foundation first
in order to get the maximum value
from your analytics and AI initiatives.
And finally, as you saw
in case of CommBank,
you can leverage Amazon SageMaker
for your data transformation journey.
And we at AWS are here to help.
With that, I'd like to
wrap up our session today.
I'd like to thank Terri and
Raghu again for co-presenting
and each one of you for
attending our session today.
I really appreciate if you could
fill up the feedback survey
that should be on the mobile app,
and thank you and have a
great rest of the re:Invent.
(audience applauds)